[Musica]
gentili non si nasce la gentilezza si
impara e poi una volta che se imparata
si sceglie di essere gentili
io sono nata negli anni settanta però
vero che ha in cui sulle bambine femmine
la pressione sociale era fortissima
nonostante una mamma femminista vi basti
pensare che per esempio i libri di
lettura quelli che trovavamo a scuola
che trovava nelle biblioteche per
raccontare i maschi eroi usavano
aggettivi come
valoroso forte
invincibile coraggioso per indicare le
bambine femmine sembra che ci fosse
dell'eroismo essere femmina e bambine
parte forse pippi calzelunghe poche
altre venivano usati aggettivi come
gentile appunto ma anche carina educata
docile pettegola ecco i miei anni
settanta stavamo messe così
io però di tutti quegli aggettivi che
dovevano indicare il mio alter ego
supereroico mi sono tenuta la gentilezza
perché sono convinta che la gentilezza
sia un superpotere la gentilezza disarma
l'avversario e apre un credito nei
confronti dell'interlocutore
considerandolo degno di attenzione e
normalmente se uno viene considerato
degno di attenzione lo diventa così come
se io ti considera intelligente tu ti
comporterai come tale io ti considero
stupito e tu farai lo stupido la
gentilezza mantiene intatti l'incanto e
lo stupore che sono due cose bellissime
io vivo in una famiglia con quattro
maschi fino a poco tempo fa con 5 poi vi
racconterò perché e io credo che in una
famiglia così o si decide di essere
gentili o non si sopravvive è in un
libro di michela murgia che si chiama
chiru a un certo punto lei dice più o
meno in ogni famiglia c'è un membro che
orienta il baricentro e motivo di tutti
gli altri ecco io trovo che essere quel
membro che oriente al mare centro
emotivo tutti gli altri ed è strano con
la gentilezza sia un privilegio e una
responsabilità enorme
inoltre sto con lo stesso uomo da 28
anni e credo che senza la gentilezza non
ce l'avremmo fatta
perché chi è gentile non si accanisse
non si incaponisce non fa polemica e
alla fin fine chi a gentile è più felice
in più ha un lavoro alle 5 del mattino
che mi obbliga a svegliarmi alle 4 noi
ci troviamo i miei colleghi ed io in un
momento in cui diamo il peggio di noi
perché quando siamo stanchi sono i
bisogni primari che prevalgono e quando
ho iniziato a lavorare lì mi hanno detto
o siamo gentili e sorridenti gli uni con
gli altri o il programma non lo portiamo
a casa adesso è l'ottavo anno che io per
programma lo porto a casa con una certa
fatica ho imparato che la gentilezza è
fondamentale insomma pratico la
gentilezza faccio yoga
sono accudenti accolgo mi sentivo
fichissima mi sentivo una campionessa
mondiale di gentilezza quando mi hanno
chiamato a fare questo ufficio ha detto
bestie è proprio il mio campo poi ci ho
pensato bene perché in realtà la
gentilezza è facile quando nuotiamo
nello stagno plus della nostra consort
son è facile quando siamo sereni quando
siamo felici il problema è quando il
gioco si fa duro i duri cominciano a
giocare e le persone gentili restano
tali
questa non è
un racconto edificante è un racconto
sullo scontro tra la teoria la teoria
che vuole volare altissimo e la pratica
che è preda delle nostre miserie dei
nostri istinti più bassi più né un
racconto di mi fa onore ma penso che
possa essere utile a tutti i voli a
tutti noi che cerchiamo di volare sul
registro altissime ogni tanto ci
schiantiamo a terra preda della nostra
natura un po misera e miserevole
noi la nostra famiglia ed io mia mamma
compresa nel novembre del 2020 abbiamo
avuto il covip del comincia travolto non
c'erano i vaccini non c'era neanche le
varianti omicron il co leader una cosa
veramente seria mia mamma è stata tre
mesi in ospedale
non eravamo affatto sicuri di
contarci ad essere lo stesso numero dopo
e prima però ce l'abbiamo fatta
e come quando succede quando ti capita
qualcosa di veramente brutto e 10 tutto
intero
un po così restituire alla vita quello
che ti a quello che ti ha regalato e
quindi io mi sono messa sul domandato
che cosa potessimo fare noi per
restituire un po di quella fortuna che
avevamo avuto a scampare quell'atrocità
che è stato il covip per noi e abbiamo
pensato che in quel periodo doveva
essere estremamente
faticoso e difficile per gli immigrati
per i rifugiati trovare casa anche
perché molti avevano paura noi appena
avendo appena avuto il co vi davamo meno
paura di altri e quindi abbiamo deciso
di accogliere un rifugiato questi
abbiamo iniziato quel percorso che un po
un percorso tipo affido adozione ed è
arrivato chiamerà camera ha 28 anni
viene dalla guinea è bello come principe
africano ed è arrivato a casa nostra
durante il mese di ramadan
all'inizio è stato bellissimo
è stato un idillio abbiamo imparato un
sacco di cose e forse anche lui le ha
imparate per esempio abbiamo imparato
molte parole
ve ne dico un paio tra tutte montanara
juan tanaro si dice quando qualcuno ha
un problema o un problema scusa dc
montanara montanara non vuol dire non
preoccuparti non vuol dire ce la farai
montanara vuol dire tutti insieme perché
tutti insieme i problemi si risolvono
un'altra parola bellissima che ci ha
insegnato è stata al barca una volta
eravamo a cena tutti insieme e lui ha
detto verso la fine della cena ai miei
figli io ho tre figli maschi
ha detto ma scusate ma come dite come
graziato i vostri genitori alla fine del
pasto per dire grazie di averci dato
anche oggi da mangiare ai miei figli che
a volte sono tre bestie sto guardati
come dire ma che no perché non li
guiderà diciamo al barca chi vuol dire
grazie papà grazie mamma per avervi
nutrito anche oggi e se non ci
ricordiamo di dire al barca regione dopo
non mangiamo e poi dice lo ricordiamo
sempre
tra le altre cose che ci ha insegnato
anzi che ci ha mostrato ma questa
bellissima che sono le prime volte
assiste alle prime volte di un bambino
per esempio molti di voi avranno vissuto
una cosa splendida vive assistere per un
adulto è una cosa magnifica per esempio
la prima volta che ha assaggiato la
marmellata di fragole quindi con una
certa ritrosia sta già tornata di
fragola e poi si è illuminato il
cioccolato bianco trovo che sia vero
privilegio assistere alle prime volte e
poi ci ha raccontato dell'inferno della
libia del suo viaggio
insomma sono stati momenti veramente
belli ha poi per esempio lui ci chiamava
mamma e papà e quando uscivamo usciva
lui lui doveva sincerarsi che la
situazione a casa fosse sotto controllo
chi c'è chi non c'è quando torni ed è
una cosa all'inizio molto bella
poiché abbiamo il tempo passa il tempo
passa e la convivenza è uno sport per
duri e quindi per esempio una ramadan lo
svegliava alle due del pomeriggio e si
piazza la sul divano in sala dove noi
facevamo smart work in piazza vali e
guardava soft porn turchi
perché netflix forse non lo sapete o
magari sì non lo so io lo sapevo ha
tutto un filone di soft porn turchi
evidentemente anche apprezzabili
sarà lì a guardarli e per esempio viveva
al buio forse per dei traumi che aveva
vissuto e quindi teneva la luce accesa
anche alle 10 del mattino col sole fuori
nei miei figli che sono fuggiti di greta
to wear che andavano fuori di testa
un'altra cosa per esempio usava la carta
igienica un rotolo al giorno e non
capivamo perché anche le miei figli
impazziti completamente ma come fai tu a
dire a uno che ha vissuto l'inferno
della libia guarda però magari la carta
igienica cerca di risparmiare magari la
luce spegnila non puoi non fa vi ho
scoperto poi che si che la zona per
asciugarsi i capelli strano diversi
capelli con la carta igienica va
comunque anche questa cosa che ci doveva
scontare riuscivo e micha dovrai mamma
due giorni mamma e dopo un po genoino
chiede mio marito né di chiedere tu
insomma piano piano subentra l'isis in
sofferenza la fatica perché la
convivenza è cosa è una cosa seria e poi
quando arriva un ospite ti guardi un po
dall'esterno e quindi io ho scoperto che
noi parliamo pochissimo che siamo
nevrotici che abbiamo quest'ansia della
produttività per cui uno che passa i
suoi pomeriggio a guardare i software
giunti su di netflix citando ci fa
andare fuori di testa norme perché
guardi software turchi che sono fatti
suoi ma chi non fa niente perché non
produce un po i milanesi in questo mio
marito e varese ma anche i baresi sono
molto così quelli insomma è stata dura i
miei figli hanno iniziato a chiudersi in
se stessi mio marito ha ricominciato a
viaggiare milano londra aveva smesso per
il college e io ho dovuto fare i conti
con
non i suoi difetti ma ovviamente i
nostri e ho capito che essere gentili
non vuol dire accettare
essere gentili vuol dire accogliere ho
capito anche che la gentilezza una
visione del mondo
qualche tempo fa ho fatto un corso di
scrittura creativa
dove la maestra ci ha detto
diffidate di chi porta pantofole a forma
di cane e guardiamoci tutti dentro e di
chi non ha una visione del mondo
ecco io credo che nella gente la
gentilezza sia un atto politico sia una
scelta politica alta e nobile che ci
rende migliore nella gentilezza bisogna
credere è questo forse il segreto della
gentilezza
questo punto camera è andato a vivere da
solo con dei suoi amici in una casa in
affitto ha trovato lavoro quindi questo
ponte che noi dovevamo usare verso
l'integrazione evidentemente ha
funzionato
ma se voi mi chiedesse
ma tu ce l'hai fatta a essere gentile
ecco più merito barese disegnato una
parola che vuol dire che vanta da juan
tando che vuol dire
arrancando fatica faticosamente poi uno
ci arriva però che fatica ecco se voi mi
fate la domanda ma ci sei riuscita può
essere gentile io risponderei
agguantando vantando grazie
[Applauso]